foreign
[Music]
is one of the hardest advancements in
recent AI technology
and it's now possible for anyone to
create their own realistic images with
just a few clicks using generative AI
studio in Google cloud in this video I'm
going to show you how you can get
started and reveal some of the tips and
tricks for getting the best results I'm
also going to show you some of the new
features of generative AI Studio that
just might change the way you work with
generated images so let's get started if
you're not already familiar with image
generation this is the technology where
you can feed an AI Model A text
description or prompt of what you want
and the AI will generate brand new
images that match that prompt
and now you can use and build with this
technology in generative AI Studio on
vertex AI
to get started we'll navigate to
generative AI studio and click through
to vision
now we enter our prompt which describes
the image we want to generate
and hit submit
an array of images will be generated so
you can take your pick of which ones you
like best
and there you have it you can directly
export and use these images for your
content apps or marketing campaigns one
tip when writing prompts is that it
helps to be as specific as possible to
generate exactly what you want
or if you're in more of an ideation
phase then you can be vague with your
prompt and let the AI generate more
random images a good prompt pattern to
follow when generating images is to
structure your prompt with the form
style then subject and then the context
for example a real life photograph of a
leafy plant sitting on a windowsill with
a blurred City in the background
when generating images you can also
configure some parameters like the size
and number of the images generated
you could also make use of the new
upscaling feature to take your generated
images and make them even more detailed
this is good if you plan to use the
images in print
now maybe you've generated an image that
you like but you want to make a slight
change to it
well in that case you can make use of
the new editing feature
if it's a small change then you can
highlight a specific region of the image
you wish to edit and then write a prompt
that describes how you want to
regenerate that region
for bigger edits you could describe how
you want to regenerate the image without
defining a mask
and voila
you can also use this feature with your
own uploaded images
so that's how you make edits to a
generated image but what if you want to
generate images of items that you have
but the model doesn't know about
for example a new product or company
logo
well the fine tuning feature has got you
covered
you can simply upload a couple of images
of the item that you want to generate
new images for and then kick off a
fine-tuning job
what's the fine tuning job is done you
can then reference that item by name in
your future prompts to generate brand
new images that include your unique item
this is a fantastic way for rapidly
generating new custom images for your
own products for marketing materials
[Music]
so those are some of the new features of
image generation in generative AI Studio
and all of them are also accessible by
an API so that you can embed image
generation technology directly into your
applications be sure to check out the
rest of generative AI studio and comment
below how you're going to use the new
image generation features
[Music]